good morning monkey good morning Beauty
what's today
the doctor day and what it's gonna
happen today
squeeze your muscles okay so yes Tiger's
right they did squeeze his arm because
um they're getting his blood pressure
because today is the big day the day
where we're gonna find out what is going
on with taika's brain uh we're at his uh
neurologist and uh this doctor was the
one that told us to get the EEG scan and
to get a CAT scan
um so yeah we got all that done and now
she's gonna go through all the results
and let us know what is going on so my
intuition and my heart of hearts tells
me he's good it was dehydration he
fainted there's nothing to worry about
but it never hurts to be 100 certain
have the science behind it and um put
any type of doubt
to rest so
yeah hoping for the best not prepared
for the worst because I don't think I
mean I don't imagine
the news being bad but I mean you never
know right so
we're waiting on the doctor now we're in
why the doctor's offices always look
so cold it's like they just randomly
throw things
up on here
I'd like you okay
[Music]
you okay
so this is the EEG that they did on
taika it's exactly this if you guys saw
our last vlog
I guess this is a normal EEG stand yeah
boy yeah boy
yeah you're pretty taller
simple partial seizures complex partial
seizures holy crap I can't tell the
difference
yeah oh it's easy it's an axon terminal
of me dude what was the red thing I'm
gonna do that this right here yeah
uh
um
pair mud pyramidal cells you didn't know
that
this one yeah
well it's the electrode electrode the
scalp the skull the dura the arc Arc
noid the Pia and then the cortex duh
so just got his test results back
everything is normal
I could breathe now I feel good we're
done we're done with anything
she says his MRI looked great EEG looked
good we're ready to rock
we did it guys
do you feel good everything's normal
do you even know what I'm talking about
no awesome
cool
okay it's not cool
why
yep I didn't let you sit down
it's very nice I'm taking care of you
that's why
he wanted to sit so we were doing the
discharge stuff
um where like you see the secretary and
she's like giving you paperwork and
stuff and like he wanted to sit in a
chair behind me and I was like nah we're
gonna leave right now
um and that's why he's mad
oh well Duty
I don't know what to tell you dude
look who we picked up and just finished
training
the monkey weasel
what's going on
it's so ticklish and I put on a seatbelt
for some reason
no dude it says it tickles his pee pee
why is pee pee poo poo so funny to you
right now
because it actually is pretty funny okay
so taika just finished his jits
um so now Papa where are we going so we
got good news
about the house we're helping our dad
get the frames are up CUNY so I'm really
excited to go there check it out send my
dad some pictures because what's really
CUNY is my dad has been on this Earth
way longer than I have you don't say and
I don't think he's ever had a house
built from scratch before
really yeah so this is a big deal you
know so so I want to go take some
pictures send it to him and then when he
moves in I for sure will take him again
so he can see like a whole house getting
erected just like in California it's
just so hard because there's so many
houses right so it's like when you're
like it's so old yeah it's older like
all the houses are like 50 70 80 years
old like when you're out in like Texas
or whatever it's much easier yeah so
it's really cool like that is
a bunch of empties that's gonna be all
houses so like someday so it's cool that
um my dad's last house which probably
his last house oh Jesus it's gonna be
brand new which is really crazy yeah I
know
all right guys so to the left of me is
my dad's CUNY house and I'm walking
behind it because we're still working at
the front so they got the generator on
and they'll go
super loud so I wish I could show you
the front but this is the stage that
it's in it has frames and the roof and
the plywood is going on and oh my God
the clouds are beautiful
yeah it's super CUNY and he has a little
yard not as big as that neighbor back
there that guy got the corner lot which
is going to be huge but my dad is you
know he's gonna be doing some basic
gardening probably plant some fruit
trees so it's gonna be super cute
typhoon will play in that little yard
area right there I'm gonna go inside and
take a look so this would be like the
rear sliding door
then you walk inside and you got like
the kitchen counter you have your living
room I believe the TV would Mount here
we'd go in and out of here
and
I also believe that room right there
with all the crisscrosses that should be
like the master the the closet and then
you have the master bath that goes
inside it's really spacious actually
look how big this place is so if you're
in the kitchen which I am right now
that's the counter that's the living
area ceiling is pretty decent height
super CUNY
so yeah as I was saying I'm extremely
excited for my dad because my dad has
never had a brand new house before and
he's going to have one and I'm so happy
that me and Geo were able to help him
with one and just take a look at the
community
it's just so peaceful and it's a gated
community with a secure wall oh my God
the sky and the clouds look beautiful
and it's going to be a really nice
change of pace because my dad lives in
Omani and if you guys are from SoCal you
know almani's the hood you know like go
out for a jog you can get bit by like
four straight dogs fools we park in the
cars on the front lawn parties keep
going until eight in the morning it is
nuts it is wild probably half the
businesses and restaurants that are
operating without permits so it's cool
for my dad to finally be in a place
where it's nice calm and quiet my dad
can go for walks
and not worry about getting run over
when I told my dad that uh his new house
is going to be in a gated community that
was one of the things he was so excited
about he was like oh really he goes yes
finally I can go on walks and not be
worried about getting run over I'm like
what that's what you've been
experiencing and why haven't you told me
so this is gonna be so awesome and my
dad's gonna live like the rest of this
life in nice peaceful awesomeness that
makes me very happy
these guys do build really fast though
because literally last week I got an
email that it was in this stage with the
cement field and then a week later it's
like bam
which is crazy so shout outs to them
shout out to them to be able to stay on
schedule because I know my dad is really
excited too so he's always asking me
like What's the progress What's the
progress I can't wait to show him this
video or he's like oh man that's where
my house is at right now I'm like yup
still scheduled to be completed by
September I believe there's always
little delays here and there but based
off how quickly it's moving I think it
should be completely fine Yes Monkey
what
he's sinking in the sand man
no it's sinking
when the house is finished it'll look
something like one of these guys there
are also two-story homes
in the area like this whole street right
here
but that's something my dad really
wanted just the one story especially
since getting older is going to go up
and down stairs so super cute looking
got like a little two garage action you
can enter from the front or enter from
the garage
I'm so excited for him
do you have a message for your grandpa
and what is it
oh you big CUNY you're such a big CUNY
dude you know that um
your break what do you mean your break
what are you talking about
okay see you later
okay so back home now and I have my
girls trip
um happening in a couple days and I've
been thinking about it and I'm so
excited especially because we all like
to look we all love to play dress up and
we're gonna celebrate one of my
girlfriend's birthdays and it'd be so
cool because we're all gonna like do
each other's makeup and get ready
everyone want to sleep in the same house
and it's going to be like the best
[ __ ] estrogen boost ever and I'm so
freaking excited I'm so excited that
I've been like picking out my outfits I
don't know what to wear
this is a this is a dress I wore to
warrants I don't know if you guys
remember that
I haven't worn these yet
because I just bought them
I think I went kind of
carried away
I have like just different outfits I'm
kind of planning throughout the day
um not sure how much or what we're going
to be doing so I kind of want to be
prepared for every single occasion
some shoesies
all sorts of colored heels these are so
funny
smells strippy straps
[Music]
you know
it's so [ __ ] fun I got like
okay monkey what do you want me to show
you I guess I flipped it on your knuckle
so you want me to Google infected
Knuckles and you want to see it yeah boy
come here let's have papa show you come
on
thank you
tell Papa to straight come here tell
Papa to show you ask him can you show me
infected Knuckles yeah that sounds like
a dope metal band I don't know it's
infected
[Music]
okay
look at that oh dude look at that one
yeah there's stuff coming out of that
one I'm not looking at any of that oh
you like this stuff dude why do you want
to see that oh look at that one oh my
goodness
okay no more monkey no more look at that
one are you gonna be a doctor is that
why no
I like to see those things you just
asked for it
I'm not gonna touch though to make them
touch it go put it on put the phone on
him and took a touch it touch it
[Music]
why you have no pants on either
oh my God all right well on that note
I'm gonna wrap up my packing
if you don't use cubes pecking cubes you
are doing travel and life and yourself a
huge disservice look at that
nice and neat super organized yeah I'm
gonna wrap it up over here call it a
night
thank you buenas noches